a headlining the main stage in Trafalgar
Square tomorrow tell us what we can
expect that's what they tell me
well my set is going to be about love we
need to spread a little bit of that we
need to remember what that is there's a
lot of hate in the world right now and I
need to encourage myself sometimes you
need to encourage yourself and this is
the best opportunity I could have so
it's going to be a set about love it's
the love step
what does pride mean to you personally
belly you know I came out in the 80s we
were in the middle of the AIDS crisis I
went to my first pride in 1989 and what
it's always meant for me and what it's
always been is a sense of community it's
a time it's always been a time and a
place for me to go into a space and
recharge with like-minded people I would
say it's a part it's a protest and a
party the two are not mutually exclusive
when I first started going you know the
marches were very much about focusing on
us getting our rights equality
you know AIDS research and all that
stuff and unfortunately we are back to a
time where our humanity and our human
rights are up for legislation again and
so I'm just happy and proud to be able
to come and be a leader with this with
this this time you look around in London
and across the UK and and there are
pride flags everywhere that there are
pride symbols up in in all of the the
big shops in offices like our own it's
the biggest ever pride in London this
year are a million people expected to
gather it's changed a lot in the 30
years since you first attended your
first Pride why do we still need pride
today
none of us are free till we're all free
none of us are equal until we all are
equal and we have to continue to remind
the world that what equality looks like
what love truly looks like you know I
believe that pride should be every day I
live my life that way and it's just to
continue it continues to be a reminder
that the LGBTQ community is here we've
always been here we will continue to be
here and we're never going anywhere so
get used to it you talked about coming
out in the 80s the height of the AIDS
crisis you'd had a difficult childhood
tell us about that that process of
coming out and and how that is
influenced the way in which you've
you've lived your life in in the
subsequent years yeah it's it's about
authenticity it's about finding a space
where you can really really truly figure
out how to love yourself because when we
can love ourselves then we teach
everything and everyone around us how to
do the same we have to honor ourselves
we have to respect ourselves and I think
the thing for me is throughout the years
the love for myself has deepened
therefore I've been able to be strong
and be powerful in these spaces and in
this movement yeah I wonder what your
your younger self growing up in
Pittsburgh would have thought to see
where you are today I don't know I I
think about I think about that often you
know that little boy who really didn't
have any place to go and really felt
very Etsy and very lost I'm
I'm very hopeful that where I'm standing
and who I am what I represent can be a
beacon of light and hope for those who
because you as a black boy gay growing
up who were you role models who did you
look to to aspire to be like did you see
anybody there were no I didn't really
see much you know there was some
historical fiction historical figures
you know you're James Baldwin's you're
by Ruston's but there wasn't a lot of
representation in a modern way in a
current way and alive you know it's been
intentional for me to place myself in
this position because I know what I want
and I'm trying to be that beacon for
others and that comes out in the roles
that you choose to play you talked about
the authenticity this isn't about Fame
so much as what it is you're portraying
being able to hold up a mirror yeah I
you know I chose my sanity over my fame
many many years ago you know I was told
that my authenticity was my liability
and I chose it anyway and the world has
caught up and I have been able to play
these roles from Belize and Angels in
America to Lola and kinky boots and now
pray tell impose on these really large
scales that have impact and have
influence I'm so grateful that I've
lived longer
see this day to see the world transform
in this way and we got to make sure that
we keep moving forward the world only
spins forward and I have to talk about
those red carpet outfits Billy Wow
pretty impressive they make a statement
but it's not just a visual statement is
it it's something more than that but
it's deeper than that
yeah it's political you know I know and
we all know that your first impression
is the one that people see people judge
you from what they see of you first and
I wanted to intentionally make sure that
when I showed up to these spaces where
all the eyes were on me that I could be
a walking piece of political art as
often as possible